let's get into last night's 2022 cmt
awards where carrie underwood continued
her streak as the most awarded artist in
cmt history with a total of 25 career
wins carrie and jason aldean earned two
trophies for their duet if i didn't love
you including video of the year which
carrie has now won
nine times here's what carrie had to say
backstage we've been in this in this
game for a while now and
for the fans to just still support us
like they do it's it's really wonderful
and it means a lot to us and um you know
it
even though i've won many cmt awards
it's just i'm still very grateful and
just know that i'm blessed and have the
best fans in the world
ah now be prepared to be blown away by
carrie's impressive performance of her
new song ghost story the pre-recorded
bit was filmed at the resorts world
theater the home of carrie's las vegas
residency yeah and taking things to new
heights carrie sang the track as she
flew through the sky amid an acrobatic
performance it's so impressive take a
look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is so impressive i don't know how
you even concentrate when you were
hanging upside down like that you don't
raw's way too dangerous it's so
dangerous
so impressive and it was so beautiful
and the song's really good yeah i like
the song she and pink her in pink those
two yeah
it takes a lot of vocal strength to be
able to sing like that and it's
incredible